rapper jada youngin has died he was 24
years old
real name javorius scott jada youngin
was shot outside his home in louisiana
local law enforcement shared details to
facebook revealing that on wednesday
police responded to a call of a shooting
where they learned one victim had
already been transported to the hospital
and another victim was still being
treated at the scene
in an update the police department
confirmed one of the victims was jada
yangan who later succumbed to his
injuries and the other victim who they
learned was a close family member was
still in stable condition law
enforcement added that an investigation
is ongoing
jd young's sister kenya janelle mourned
her brother on instagram writing i'm
sick to my stomach i'm so sorry i love
you so much straight to the top
jd youngin was an up-and-coming rapper
known for songs like ops and elimination
[Music]
in 2020 the singer celebrated his debut
studio album 23 island released by
atlantic records the label said in a
statement this is a senseless loss of an
immensely talented artist with his whole
life in front of him our deepest
condolences to his family and everyone
who loved him
you